[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
لحركه الطيران الامريكيه واشنطن تحقق في
صدمه شلل النظام وخصائر كبيره للقطاع
ما فهمت كمان
لانشاء شبكه دفاع جويه وكبدتها ملايين
دولار
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
تراجع قياسي للجنيه المصري امام الدولار
خبراء متفائلون باختفاء السوق الموازيه
والحكومه تتجه
[موسيقى]
الوارده عن المراقبه الجويه الكنديه هذه
المراقبه تقول ان النظام للطيران يواجه
انقطاع عن ايضا ولا تاخير في الرحلات ليس
هناك اي تاثير على الرحلات حتى الان ولكن
يبدو ان هذا الانقطاع يمتد بعد يوم في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى كندا مبدع
عينا على ما يحصل هناك ولكن ابرز ما حصل
امريكيا فبعد الصدمه دامت عده ساعات تاني
فات حركه الطيران في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن التساؤلات لا تزال قائمه
حول السبب فكيف بدات قصه راويه
مفاجاه الاجهزه المعنيه يطهر بعطل في نظام
نور الخاصه بمعلومات السلامه للرحلات
الجويه ليتخذ قرار سريع بوقف عمليات
الاقلاع من المطارات الامريكيه
المطارات الخارجيه بوقف ارسال رحلات جويه
الى المطارات الامريكيه الى حين اصلاح
الخلل
الطائرات التي كانت تحلق في الاجواء
الامريكيه على الهبوط بسلام وهو ما تم
بطريقه غلب عليها الجهد البشر
اعلنت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه عبر
حسابها في تويتر انها قررت استئناف الحركه
الجويه العاديه تدريجيا في جميع انحاء
لكن ما الذي يعنيه هذا الخلل الفني
بالارقام بحسب مواقع متخصصه فقد تسبب
العطل تسبب هذا العطل يا طاهر في ارتباك
حركه الطيران ليصله الرقم الى تعرض اثنا
عشر الف الى التاجيل الغاء ولم تختبر
الولايات المتحده ازمه واسعه النطاق كهذا
منذ هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر عام 2001
حين اغلقت المجال
الجويهفع شركات الطيران الى المزيدي من
التشكيك في موثوقيه التحتيه لادايه اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه
بالنسبه لهذه الشركات وللشركات العامله في
مجال خدمات طيران الارقام الاوليه تتحدث
عن ثلاثه مليارات دولار لكن الرقم قد يزيد
يطهر الان الى السبب الان السبب غير معروف
حتى الان اذا لكن اكثر من جهه تسعى ورائه
البيت الابيض اوضح انا بيضا طالب وزاره
النقل بفتح تحقيق شامل بشان العطل الذي
تسبب في حاله شلل غير مسبوقه لقطاع
الطيران
انه لا يوجد دليل على ان تعطل نظام اداره
طيران الاتحاديه كان بسببه هجوم الكتروني
اما المشرعون الامريكيون الذين قاموا
بادوار رئيسيه في الاشراف على اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه
الو انهم سيحققون من جانبهم في الخلل الذي
اصابع نكمل
ماريا كانتوال وهي رئيسه لجنه التجاره
بمجلس الشيوخ ان التحقيق سيهدف لمنع تكرار
هذه الواقعه مشدده على ان الامريكيين
يحتاجون لنظام نقل جوي مرن وشاركها الرئيس
في لجنه النقل بمجلس النواب وقال ان
النواب سيواصلون المتابعه مع وزاره النقل
لضمان حل هذه المشكله جذريا ناديه قلب
البيسي تابع التطورات الازمه منذ الصباح
ووفتنا بالمزيد
اذا عوده حركه الملاحه الى طبيعتها في
المطارات الامريكيه هنا في مطار الدلس في
ولايه فرجينيا نرى الطائرات تهبط وتقلع
بسلام دون اي مشاكل طبعا هيئه الملاحه
قالت بنها سترفع الحظر وبالفعل رفعته نرى
بعض المسافرين هنا الذين ينتظرون حقائبهم
لكن رحلات الخارجيه لم تتاثر تحدث مع اكثر
من مسافر اتو من الخارج قالوا بانهم حتى
لم يعرفوا بالموضوع او بهذا الخلل لكن
التدعيات السياسيه ستكون كبيره وخصوصا في
مجلس النواب الذي سيطلب موسى من وزير
المواصلات طبعا الحديث الان هو عن عطل فني
في داخل الحاسوب الاساسي الذي يزود
الملاحين او الصيادين بالمعلومات الاساسيه
لذا كجراء احترازي تم همم حظر جميع
السيارات الطائرات في المطارات الامريكيه
من الاقلاع لكن همم استبعاد له سيبراني
الرئيس بعد ان قال بانه لا يعرف السبب لكن
هناك تحقيق شامل ومساءله وخصوصا لاداره
الرئيس بايدن حتى لو لم يكن الخطر امني لا
الامر غير مقبول بالنسبه للجمهوريين
وبالنسبه للامريكيين لماذا يحدث هذا الخطا
الذي يتسبب بملايين من الدولارات في
الخسائر لكن العوده حتى الان الطبيعيه على
الاقل في مطار دالاس في ولد برج الجدي
مراسل العربيه حسين التوضا اهلا بك معنا
حسين الوضع الان في المطار عندك وفي بقيه
مطارات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهمم
عما تكشفت الامور بعد ما اكل حصل بعد كل
ما حصل اليوم
[موسيقى]
تحيه لكما طاهر وراويه بالفعل انا في مطار
رونالدو المحاضره للعاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن الرحلات استئنافته ولكن عدد
الرحلات الملغات وعدد الرحلات التي تم
تاجيلها يزداد في الحقيقه طاهره لا نتحدث
عن اكثر من ثمانيه الاف رحله تم تاجيلها
وذلك بسبب اعاده جدول الرحلات التي تاخرت
في ساعات الصباح الاولى ما خلق مشكله اذا
نظرنا هنا على على هذه الشاشات التي تظهر
البيانات هناك عدد من الرحلات التي تم
الغائها والملغات وهناك بعض الرحلات في
الحقيقه في اللون الاحمر هي ما زالت عندها
توقيتها وهذه الرحلات هي اذا لاحظنا هي
الرحلات التي اصلا كانت مجد ولا لا همم في
ساعات ما بعد الظهر يعني هي لم تتاثر
كثيرا همم ما جرى خلال ساعات الصباح
الاولى ولكن ال- ال- المسافرون عندما
ياتوننا للمطار همم
عدد كبير منهم همم في صفوف طويله همم يقف
في صفوف طويله هناك الناس دي حام بسبب كما
قلنا اعاده الجدول هذه هذا المشهد لما
نراه خلال ساعات الصباح الاولى عندما كانت
معظم الطائرات موجوده على الارض حتى
الساعه 9:00 كان هناك عدد كبير من
الطائرات على
المدرج حتى الساعه 9 بدانا نرى الطائرات
تطير هذا كله ادى الى زياده المشكله وطبعا
لها تداعيات من من غير متوقع ان تحل هذه
المشكله الليله او اليوم ربما تبقى ايام
كما حدث خلال نهايه راس العام عندما كان
هناك مشكله مع طيران سعودي
استمرت المشكله على مدى اكثر من ثلاث او
اربعه ايام من المتوقع ان مشاهده هذه
المشكله غدا ايضا همم في ظل كما قل اعاده
الجدول المزيد من الرحلات وارتفاع عدد
الرحلات الملغات والرحلات التي تم تاجيلها
طلب تحقيقا حول اسباب ما حصل من تعطيل
بحركه الطيران الامريكيه همم من الجهه
الرسميه انا من الجهه التي سيعتمد على
التقريرها وحتى الان هل تسربت اي معلومات
حول سبب ما حصل
الجهه الرسميه طبعا عندنا وزاره النقل
الامريكيه وايضا اداره طيران الفيدراليه
همم هاتان الجهتان هي تابعه لوزاره النقل
هما من قمان بهذا التحقيق الذي حتى الان
يستبعد ان يكون السبب هجوم سيبراني او عمل
الارهابي حتى الان الحديث عن خلال قديم
همم اضافه الى ما تفضلتم وذكرتموه في
الخبر قبل قليل حتى السنه الجمهوري قد
الكوز دعى الى اعاده هيكله هيئه الطيران
اداره الطيران الفيدراليه ودعى الى ان
يكون على راسها مسؤول ثابت له خبره في
مجال الطيران هذه الايه حتى الان لا
يراسها احد همم هناك المزيد من الدعوات في
القاموس الامريكي ان كنا نتحدث عن مجلس
الشيوخ همم مجلس النواب الذي يسيطر عليه
الجمهوريون ليكون هناك جلسات استماع
لمعرفه ما حدث لكي لا يتكرر ذلك بالمناسبه
وزير النقل بجاج ايضا دا اليوم عن قرار
اداره النقل الفيدراليه وقال ان هذا
القرار القرار كان صحيحا همم كاجراء
احترافي حتى لا يكون هناك اي حادث ولكنه
في الوقت نفسه قال ان الوقت الان هو الوقت
المناسب لاعاده همم دراسه التقنيات
التكنولوجيا التي تستخدمها هذه الاداره في
مجال النقل الجوي شكرا جزيلا لك حسين
الطود مراسل للعربيه من مطار رونالد
ما هو
» تحديدا ولماذا سبب كل هذه المشكله
نظام يا طاهر يقدم اشعارا للموظفين
بمعلومات السلامه المهمه بالنسبه للرحلات
الجويه والمخاطر التي قد تؤثر على الرحلات
لكن في الحقيقه بدا العمل به منذ اكثر من
75 عاما
واخذت فكرته من نظام المماثل كان يقدم
النصائح لقباطنه السفن قبل الابحار في علي
البحار تتناول اشعارات التحذير نتا من
مخاطر القفز بالمظلات والعروض الجويه
والطائرات الشراعيه وتنبيه للرحلات الجويه
التي تحمل رؤساء الدول على الارض التحذير
من المدارس والممرات المغلقه او حتى وجود
عوائق مؤقته مثل الرافعات في المطار او
حتى اضواء المدارس المعطله
كبير ولا سنوات لكن في عام 2017 عندما
حاول طائره الهبوط في سان فرانسيسكو لم
تكون معلومات سلامه واضحه وطعم وكادت
الطائره ان تصطدم باربع طائرات اخرى كانت
متوقفه بالمطار ووصل الامر
بروبس المجلس الوطني لسلامه النقل الى حد
وصف اشعارات نوتان بانها مجموعه من
القمامه التي لا يهتم بها احد ومن وقتها
خضع النظام لتحسنه عديده
[موسيقى]
واحلى هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القاهره
عبر زوم الكابتن محمود الطيار وخبير
السلامه الجويه اهلا بك كابتن محمود يعني
حاول ما حصل اليوم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حصلت مشكله مشابهه هناك بعام
ووقتها لم تكن المشكله
بتعطل هذا النظام نظام نوتام وانما كانت
بعدم قدره التيارين وقتها على قراءه
وتفسير الاشعارات بكل ما حصل اليوم وكل
المعصيات الموجوده حتى الان هل هنالك من
مؤشرات لديك تقول انه هذا الذي حصل هو عطل
تقني ام انه ربما تدخل او هجوم خارجي
برحب بحضرتك وباستاده المشاهدين طبعا هو
واضح جدا ان هو عطل غريب من نوعه فريد من
نوعه لاول مره يحصل منذ تطبيق نظام
الميتام وهو زي ما اشارتهم في التقرير ان
هو نوت 2 او
يعني او اختار لي الطيارين من اشعارات
ومعلومات مهمه تخص الطيران وتخص الرحله
همم الامر فريد من نوعه وجديد ولكنه همم
يعني ليس له سابقا من قبل همم وهذا مؤشر
يدل على شيء غير طبيعي انهيار النظام
بالكامل بهذا الشكل او بهذه الكيفيه همم
يعني امر غير طبيعي لان هناك ايضا في عالم
الطيران في كل الانظمه يجب ان يكون نظام
بديل ونظام غالي وغير غالي فهذه كلها
مؤشرات تدل على انه حدث غير طبيعي ولكن
عندما نضيف عامل كندا الان لانه المراقبه
الجويه كنديه قبل قليل قالت نظام اوتام
للطيران يواجه انقطاعا ولكن لا تاخير على
الرحلات ماذا يعني ذلك
هذا يعني انه هناك عرض مؤثر على هذه
المنطقه بالكامل بالمناسبه همم له اسباب
كثيره ومتعدده وربما ايضا لها علاقه بشبكه
الانترنت نفسها همم
وربما ايضا يكون له بعض هناك بعض
الفيروسات الغير همم يعني ممكن نقول الغير
همم مخلقه او غير مقصوده من الممكن ان
تهاجم النظام ايضا همم جميع الحلول مطروحه
ولا نستطيع ابدا ان نستبعد
المحور او يعني الحل الذي يقول ان هناك
استهداف لهذا لان طبعا الامر عارض وغير
طبيعي ويستحق التحقيق بدقيقه
يعني اا عندما نتحدث عن هناك عارض يؤثر
بهذا النظام هل وافقت فيروسات يعني ما
اشكال همم التعرض التي يمكن ان تؤثر على
هكذا نظام ولماذا ب- اا كندا واجا انقطاعا
ولكن لا تاخير بالرحلات بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حصل هناك تاخير وايقاف للرحلات
لان انقطاع المعلومه عن التيار يمنع وجود
الرحله لان المعلومه التي يوفرها نظام هو
معلومه مهمه جدا همم ولا احد شروط قيام
الرحله من الاصل لان برنامج الرحله يقام
عليها همم التسلسل الاحداث وطبيعتها يدل
على انه امر غير طبيعي هو لم يحدث من قبل
وليس له مثيل حدث من قبل ولكنه في نفس
الوقت همم يعني همم
يعني امر اعرض وامر جديد وهنا وهو امر من
صنع البشر فربما يكون حدث خلنا الامر الذي
فعلا يدعو الى العجب والاستغراب ان حتى
الحلول البديله غير موجوده ايضا هناك
علامه استفهام موجوده تحتاج الى اجابه في
التحقيقات
تسبب في عطل في النظام الطيران الداخلي
الامريكا اما ال- ال- اما في الرحلات
الدوليه فهي ما زالت بحاله انتظام ومن
طالب طيب بس بالنسبه للبدائل قلت حضرتك
انه لا توجد بدائل على الاطلاق يعني اذا
كان الانقطاع كاملا او شبه كامل لابد من
وقف حركه الطيران بالمطلق ام ان الاجراء
الذي تخذ كان يعني احترازيا اكثر
وفي الاصل وهو في الاصل المفروض انه اذا
حدث انقطاع لا يكون كامل لكن فكره كامل
هذا امر جديد ان لا يكون هناك حلول بديله
هذا امر غير غير مطروح في الطيران المدني
الطيران المدني قائم على المحاور والحدود
فانه يكون هناك عدم وجود حلول
الامر ينقطع بالكامل ده امر صعب جدا وغير
ذلك ولم يكن مطروح طب ليش رجع الهبوط
بالاول وبعدين
همم
الهبوط لا هو اللي وقف اللي هبوط بالكامل
وتم التصريح بالاقلاع لفتره وبعدين وقف
الاقلاع يمكن حبه يعتمده على
التقارير اللي ما زالت صالحه
المسؤولين واضحه بانه الهبوط ماتا مسموحا
ولكن الاقلاع على يزال غير مسموح في فتره
ماء من فتره الانقطاع قبل على الاستئناف
دعم ده ده ده اسباب كثير لان اهمها ان
الطائره في الجو والطائره همم لن تستطيع
ان تطير الى الى الابد فهنا
والولايات المتحده كبيره ويجب ان يؤكد ان
هناك
تمام تمام
لو سمحت دوله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كيف لا يكون لديها نظام بديل في حال حاله
استثنائيه كالتي حصلت اليوم هو من الواضح
ان العارض الذي حدث ضرب النظام الاساسي
والبديل ماما
وتسبب في عطل كامل وهذا ما يشير بشده الى
انه امر غير طبيعي وانه ليس مجرد سقوط
لنظام او الانقطاع لشبكه الانترنت في هذا
المكان شكرا جزيلا على هذه التوضيح
الطيار وخبير السلام الجويه عبرزه من
القاهره تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه نجاح بعد اخر في
اوكرانيا يعزز السمعه العسكريه لكنه يزيد
الشكوك حول الاخلاقيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد روايات المتضاربه
اكدت مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه سيطرتها على
مدينه سوليدر شرق اوكرانيا ومقتل 500 جندي
اوكراني خالفت فاجنر رغبه الكراملين الذي
اكد اهميه عدم التسرع في اعلان الانتصار
في سوليدار وانتظار الاعلان الرسمي مشيرا
الى وجود تقدم للقوات الروسيه في البلده
بدورها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها حاصرت فولدار من الشمال والجنوب
بينما قصف سلاح الجو مواقع اوكرانيه في
البلده هذا الاعلان سبقه تاكيد قائد
مجموعه
بعد معارك كثيفه خلال الاسبوع الحالي
مضيفا ان قتال الشوارع متوسط الجيش
الاوكراني الطرف الاهم في المعادله اصدر
بيانا قد يبدو يائسا مؤكدا ان البلده
ستبقى اوكرانيه تصريحات لا تحتاج لتفسيرات
توضح انها مساله وقت وستكون سوليدار تحت
سيطره روسيا
كل ما يدور اليوم
الاكثر دمويه لهذه الحرب اي اننا نرى مثل
هذا الموقف غير المسؤول تماما بعباره اكثر
لطفا موقف النخبه الروسيه تجاه افرادها
العسكريين الذين يموتون هناك بالالاف هناك
الكثير من الدماء والمعارك بالمدفع عند
خاصه في سوريا دار اليوم هذه هي البقعه
الاكثر سخونه في الحرب
السيطره على سوليدار قد لا تغير وجه
المعركه من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه ولكن
معنويه سيكون المفعول كبيرا اذ تتصارع
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه عليها منذ
اشهر لدرجه ان الحياه فيها باتت غير
موجوده من شده القتال لكن سقوط سوليدار قد
يمثل نقطه انطلاق للقوات الروسيه من اجل
تطويق مدينه بخبط القريبه التي تسعى روسيا
للسيطره عليها منذ الصيف الماضي وتقعوا
على خط امداد استراتيجي بين منطقه
اللتين تتالف منهما من تقدم بس اهم منطقه
الصناعيه في اوكرانيا ومن شان السيطره على
مخنوقه منح روسيا منطلقا للتقدم نحو
مدينتين اكبر هما اكرام تورسك
وسلوفيانسكار وبحسب المخابرات البريطانيه
فان روسيا تسعى على الارجح من خلال محورها
في سوليدار الى
مخموت من الشمال وتعطيل خطوط التواصل
الاوكرانيه رائد الاخبار معه المزيد
اكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان جيشها سيطر على
المناطق الشماليه والشرقيه من مدينه
سيلدار واضافت ان معارك ضاريه ما زالت وسط
المدينه وقل قائد قوات بادنر الخاصه ان
جنوده سيطروا على وسط المدينه وطهروها من
ديون المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في ذات الوقت
الذي ما زالت فيه معارك ضاريه بين الجيش
الاوكراني والروسي في مناطق غرب المدينه
وتشير مصادره الى وصوله امدادات عسكريه
اوكرانيه الى نفس المحور لتعزيز دفاعاتكيه
بينما تتقدم القوات الروسيه من المحور
الشمالي نفسه للوصول الى مدينه سيفر التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني شمالا مقاطعه
دانيسك بينما تطوق كامل القوات الروسيه
مدينه باخمط وتنطلق من بلده اوبتنا نحو
العمقي في تلك المدينه نحو مدينه ايفانكا
[موسيقى]
عندما برز اسمه معركه سوليدار سلطت
الاضواء على نجاحات قوات فاجنر الروسيه
الخاصه تلك المجموعه الاكثر سريه في
العالم كما نعرف راويه والتي تتضارب
الانباء عنها وعن ماهيتها بين تصريحات
روسيه وتقارير غربيه نتعرف عليها اكثر معك
الشعر يا طاهر الذي قد يكون غير رسمي لكنه
متداول في روسيا على نطاق واسع ويصف في
الوقت ذاته حالهم بامتياز الموت هو عملنا
وهو يسيل جيدا فكلما وجدت صراعا لا تستطيع
ان تتدخل فيه روسيا رسميا عبر جيشها فيمكن
حينها سماع اسم فاجنر التي كان في موسكو
اي علاقه رسميه بها ترددت الانباء عن
فاجنر في سوريا ليبيا ومالي وجنوب افريقيا
واخيرا اوكرانيا فعندما لم يستطع الجيش
حسب المعارك في دوم بس كانت فاجنر الحل
البدايه كانت عند
غينيا
طباخ بوتين الذي هذا كان لقمه الذي اطلق
عليه لان بدايته كانت كصاحب مطعم ومتعهد
طعام للكرامنت ثم اسس الشركه واصبح حتى
تتخذ الان مركزا رئيسا في مدينه سان
بطرسبرج وتعتمد بشكل رئيسي على تجنيد قدام
المحاربين الذين يحتاجون الى سداد الديون
والتغطيه التكاليف الحياه وكسب المال فيما
تتحدث التقارير الغربيه عن مقاتليها
ومعظمهم كان عليهم احكام السجن ننتقل الى
البيت الابيض لناستمع الى المتحدثه همم
باسم البيت الابيض
وكذلك همم سمعنا اننا ليس لدينا دليل على
ان هذا القطار نتيجه لهجوم من سبراني
حول الاسباب
للتاكد من ان هذا لم يتكرر
سوريا سوريا
التربيه والتعليم خطه تعليميه جديده
وبالتالي فانها تقلل
صفات وستجعل اقل من 30,000
يكون هناك
سيكون هناك
للطلبات من اجل تسديد القروض واليوم لدينا
ادله جديده على الخطه الاقتصادي
للعماله الامريكيه
ايه
مسدسات اكثر من اثنين فاصل خمسه مليار
دولار لتوسعه 1000 مصنع
جورج
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض التي اكدت
فيها انه لادا ليل حتى الان ان الذي حصل
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتوقف حركه
الملاحه هو نتيجه هجوم سيبراني وان
السلطات تحقق لعدم تكرار الموضوع نتابع به
فاجنر مجله نيوز بيك نشرت تقريرا استعانت
فيه بخبره عسكريين ومراقبين كشفت فيه ان
يفقين
يحاول استغلال معركه سوليدار لتعزيز ثم
ادفاجنر كقوه قتاليه قادره على الحسد بعض
اخر اظهره التقرير ان بينجو يحاول تعزيز
خزائنه ومواصله اعماله عبر تمويل
المقاتلين
المراقبون اكدوا ان طبخه بوتين يريد ان
يثبت كفاءه مقاتلين وسط المنافسه المتعثره
للجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا وعدم جاهزيه
الجنود الروسي بالنظر الى نتائج عام على
القتال في اوكرانيا نجد ان حرب الشوارع
كانت الطاغيه على الصراع والتي فشل فيها
الجيش الروسي بامتياز فيما نجحت فيه فاجنر
حتى الان اذن المعايير الاخلاقيه قد تكون
معدومه لديهم فهم يقاتلون من اجل المال
اما ان يقتلوا او يقتلوا مهما كانت
الوسيله وصور الدمار الهائل التي نراها في
سوليدار دليل واضح على ذلك
[موسيقى]
معنى من لندن
العسكريه والامنيه اهلا بك معنا سيد فوكس
في العربيه 360
لماذا
تنجح حيث تفشل القوات الرسميه
ايهاب عليكم
سباق في استعراض القوه بين
يفجيني والذي يروج لنفسه
قد ظهرت
تعكسه الصور
بين صفوف الجنود وهناك انترا لكثير من
الاموال وبالتالي يركزون في قواتهم على
همم
استخدامي تكتيكات الجديده في سوداء وبخوت
طيب
النجاح الذي
فاجنر باي معركه تخوضها وخاصه باوكرانيا
هل قد يكون يعني تمهيد لدور اكبر قد يكون
لهم بالجيش الروسي نتحدث ربما عن اندماج
نتحدث ربما عن سيطره ودور اكبر لرئيسها
باريس
هي الشركه مستقله
ونشاطاتهم مره ثانيه في ليبيا وخاصه في
الدول الغنيه بالمعادن في
الساحل في دول الساحل الافريقي وكذلك في
مناجم الذهب وانت محقه دعم ان هناك خشيه
بانهم يطورون هذه القوه
ليسيطر وهو بالتالي
كالدوله داخل دوله
طيب سيد روبرت فوكس من الخاص الى العم في
ما يتعلق بالتغييرات العسكريه التي تشهدها
هذه العمليه الان رئيس الاركان هو الذي
سيتولى قياده العمليات في اوكرانيا هل
تعتقد انه لهذه التغييرات
تاثير ايجابي في المستقبل القريب وهل
الموضوع متعلق باشخاص يقودون هذه المعركه
هو الذي يتولى
الان هو قائد العمليات وشرفك
الجنرال
في الدفاع الجوي وهو وراء الحمله الجويه
اااه ومعروف في حلب و دمشق وهذا
يطرح السؤال
من يقود
همم
خسائر كبيره في منطقه ما خطوه نعرفه كذلك
انهم عززوا وجودهم
بقوات قوات النخبه من الجيش الروسي وخاصه
الباراشوت
والقوات الجويه
لا يهمني من يقود الاعمال القتاليه
باعتبار ان القدر هو من عند الله كل قوي
يجد الاقوام منه
روا الذين يعتبرون من قوات روسيا
بهم باعتبارهم مقاتلين جدا
[موسيقى]
سلامه الطيران هو سبب وقف حركه الملاحه في
البلاد ونواصل التحقيق في اسباب هذا
القطاع
اذا سنوات من الضربات التي تواجهها توجهها
اسرائيل فعليا للمواقع الايرانيه داخل
سوريا وهدفها كما تقول من علمي مليشيات
الايرانيه من التمددي اضافه لمنع تهريب
السلاح الى حزب الله لبنان
بحسب مصدر استخباراتيه من دوله متحالفه مع
الولايات المتحده بان ايران سعد الى انشاء
شبكه دفاع جوي شامله في سوريا مشيرا الى
انها قامت فعلا بارسال معدات وافراد
لانشائها النظام المصدر كشف ان
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه تغيرت اخره عامين
حيث قام الطهران بتعزيز نشري قدراتي دفاع
جوي لصالحها في سوريا
بتاكلوفه وصلت لعشرات الملايين من
الدولارات
تم كم مشروع المشترك مع قوات النظام
السوري بهدف زرع النظام الايراني المستقل
للدفاع الجوي داخل سوريا
النظام في تحديث مجموعه من الرادارات
الخاصه بهم وشملت الاسلحه صاروخ صياد الذي
يعمل بالوقود اربعه بي- الصلب وتم دمج
القديفه مع نظام صواريخ
373 ارجون ويقال ان مداها يزيد عن 186
ميلا مع مدى رادار يزيد عن 280 ميلا
[موسيقى]
والان قائد مجموعه فاجنر يقول انه قواته
عثرت على جثه احد البريطانيين اللذين اعلن
عن اختفائهما في وهما متطوعان في اوكرانيا
بناء على بيان صابر عنه
الدفاع الجوي الايرانيه التي يتم تركيبها
تحديدا على الاراضي السوريه قرب قوات
النظام وهو ما جعل الاخيره تحت خطر
الضربات الاسرائيليه
حيث تم استهداف خلال العامين الماضيين فقط
بحسب تقارير سبع شبكات ايرانيه للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا بما في ذلك في تدمر وترطوس
في اكتوبر 20 21 والذيقيه في ديسمبر 20 21
ودمشق في مارس 20 22 وضربه اضافيه في
طرطوس في يوليو 20 22 اضافه الى ضربتين في
حمص في نوفمبر وديسمبر من 20-2-20 وعلى
مدار السنوات القليله الماضيه قتل 10
ايرانيين في غارات جويه اسرائيليه في
سوريا وتم تحديد ايرانيين اثنين قتل في
القاره الجويه في مارس من عامه 20 22 وهما
مرتضى سعيد نجاد واحسان كربلاء
كلاهما مهندسا دفاع شاوي»
[موسيقى]
وفي اعلان النادر اكدت ايران مقتل العقيد
داوود جعفري احد مستشاري القوات الجويه
للحرس الثوري في سوريا والمعروف ايضا باسم
مالك
ايراني اوضح ان جعفري قتل بعبوه ناسفه
استهدفت سيارته بالقرب من العاصمه السوريه
دمشق في اواخر نوفمبر الماضي دون ذكر مزيد
من التفاصيل عن حادثه الاغتيال وظروفها
تقرير سوري المعارض بحسب موقع صوت العاصمه
حيث افاد بان العقيد جعفر قتل اثناء عودته
من جوله استطلاعيه سريه بالقرب من الحدود
مع اسرائيل
تعمدت اعلان استهداف جعفري بالقرب من دمشق
تجنبا لفتح مهام ضباطها في الجنوب السوري
وعلى الشريط الحدودي مع اسراء اسرائيل
وفي هذه الاثناء يا طاهر داعش تتبنى
الهجوم الانتحاري قرب الخارجيه الافغانيه
في كابول ومن الناصره ينضم الينا نظير
مجالي المحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد نظير
يعني ما الذي نتوقعه من خريطه من حكومه
نتنياهو الجديده يعني حكومه يمنيه فيها
جناح متطرف ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله بالايام
القادمه في ما يخص الضربات الاسرائيليه
على سوريا
مساء الخير لكما في الاستوديو واحلام
الاخوه المشاهدين والمشاهدات في اسرائيل
طبعا يستعدون للمرحله القادمه ويضعون قضيه
ايران في راس سلم الاهتمام نتنياه تحدث
امس عندما زار الحدود الشماليه تكلم بشكل
واضح عن هذا الموضوع وقال انه اليوم يضع
في راس الاهتمام تصفيه الوجود الايراني في
سوريا لا يريد اي موضوع نشر الجديد حول
هذه المنظومه الصاروخيه طبعا فتح الباب
امام عده تحيلات جديده في اسرائيل تقول ان
هذا تطور كبير
وهم يرصدون التعاون الايراني الروسي في
اوكرانا ويرجون ان هناك اسلحه جديده
تظهرها ايران
ويتمبارها في المعارك على الارض وهي تقلق
اسرائيل بشكل همم جده ولذلك يعني تستعد
لمواجهه هذا الموضوع وعندما تتطرق لهذه
النقطه بالذات يقصدون تصفيات كل من مساله
منظومه الصاروخ الصواريخ التي من الممكن
ان تطلق وتعرق الغارات الاسرائيليه كما هو
معروف حتى الان همم الغارات الاسرائيليه
تتم من دون اي همم تمكن سوري من اسقاط اي
طائره مع انه هنالك صواريخ يتم اطلاقها
وافلد سوريا يوجد همم صواريخ اس 3 وحتى
الان اا روسيا لم ااه تدرب السوريين على
استخدامهم ولذلك هي لا تستخدم فايران تقيم
منظومه كهذه اولا احتياطا في حال قامت
اسرائيل بقصف ايراني مباشر وثانيا تريد
جدا معنيه بان يتم استخدامها ايضا في
سوريا وتحاول ان تقنع الروس بان يقبل بذلك
حتى الان الروس لم يوافق روسيا اي زي ايضا
حساباتهم ينتظرون كيف ستتجه انذار حكومه
نتنياهو هل ستتخذ موقفا مختلفا في موضوع
الحرب في اوكرانيا يكون ضد روسيا مثلا
فتتحرك روسيا على الارض السوريه ضد
اسرائيل او يكون هناك تفاهم وعلاقات افضل
في الموضوع في اوكراينا حتى تكون مرنه
اكثر اتجاه اسرائيل فتمنع ايران استخدام
هذه الصواريخ ما الخيارات الاكبر التي لدى
اسرائيل يعني بمعنى في تقييماتها العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه هل اتت كل طرائقها همم
اكلها فيما يتعلق بمحاربه هذا النظام الذي
ارادت ايران اقامته على الاراضي السوريه
اما انها تجد الان بانه لابد من ايجاد
بدائل او اللجوء الى خيارات همم اكثر قوه
لمنعها لانها مستمره رغم كل الدرجات التي
تلقتها
رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي المنتهيه
مدته
لخص الدوره التي قاد فيها الجيش بانها
افشلت المخطط الايراني تماما في التموضع
في سوريا الان عندما بداوا يتحدثون عن
صواريخ فهذا كشف جديد وفي اسرائيل حتى
الان لم يتطرقوا اليه بشكل مباشر ولكن
واضح ان الهدف الاسرائيلي الاول هو منع
ايران من تواضع في سوريا وليس فقط ايران
يعني ليس فقط الجيش الايراني او قوات
الحرس الثوري الايرانيه انما يتحدثون ايضا
عن السياده المختلفه توجد من اشياء اضافه
الى حزب الله اللبناني توجد مليشيات اخرى
في الاراضي السوريه تابعه لايران وكل هذه
تتعرض لحرب متواصله من القوات الاسرائيليه
وفيما يتعلق في التصعيد هذه المعركه
باتجاه ايران يكون الامر مختلف طبعا لان
اسرائيل حتى الان لا يوجد فيها قرار ان
تحارب ايران مباشره تنتظر الولايات
المتحده وطبعا العلاقات الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه في هذه الفتره مع الحكومه
الجديده حتى الان غيرت واضحه يعني سياتي
نتنياهو الى الولايات المتحده في الشهر
القادم وربما هذا الموضوع سيكون طبعا على
راس سلم اهتمام هل ممكن ان يتوصل الى
طريقه واحده للتفاعل في هذا الموضوع ام لا
في مجال لي المحلل
[موسيقى]
السياسي
الذي ورد قبل قليل عن قائد فاجنر يقول لا
ياتي على ذكر اسم البريطاني القتيل ولكن
يقول في البيان بانه الوثائق التي وجدت
على الجثمان تعود الى همم كلاي
البريطانيين المفقودين دون ان يحدد الاسم
اذا هناك وثائق تتعلق بالرجلين ولكن لم
يحدد من هو البريطاني القتيل وكان اعلن عن
اختفاء اثنين او عن فقدان اثنين بريطانيا
في اوكرانيا
الى افغنستان يا طاهره الان حيث منذ قليل
اتمنى الداعش الهجوم الانتحاري قرب
الخارجيه الافغانيه في كابول ولدي اوقع
خمسه قتلى وعددا من المصابين
هويته بعد
دقائق اذا كما قلت راويه عن تبنيه للعمليه
[موسيقى]
برر نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان بلال
كريم قرار حكومه طالبان منع تعليم المراه
في الجامعه بانه بانه واجبها تنظيم شؤون
التعليم والتنميه في البلاد وفقا لاحكام
الشرع
حقوقا لم تكن موجوده في السماء
[موسيقى]
تتكون من علماء وطلاب يهتمون بالعلوم
والتربيه والتعليم
اي شخص باي شكل من الاشكال ولكنها مسؤوله
عن تنظيم المراحل التربويه والتعليميه وكل
ما يتعلق بذلك فهي مسؤوله وترى ان من
واجبها ان يكون ذلك وفقا لاحكام الشريعه
الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
وتتابعون المقابله كامله لنائب المتحدث
باسم طالبان بلال كريمي الخميس
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
في خاركي في الاوكرانيه الالعاب الناريه
ليست دائما مصدرا للبهجه قد تكون احيانا
قاتله
[موسيقى]
تراجع التاريخي للجنيه المصري امام
الدولار
صندوق النقد الدولي ان اي تدخل للمركزي
المصري يجب ان يكون بهدفي تهدئه الطاقه
قد وصلت في ديسمبر الماضي لاتفاق مع صندوق
النقد الدولي يتيح لها تمويلا بقيمه 3
مليارات دولار لمده 48 شهرا
للمره الاولى تنخفض قيمه الجنيه المصري
لتكسر حاجز ال 29 امام الدولار الامريكي
البنك المركزي لم يعلق على هذه التطورات
التقديرات تشير بان الاحتياط المصري يبلغ
34 مليار دولار اغلبها ودائع خارجيه من
قبل الدول الخليجيه ومن المتوقع وبحسب
خبراء ان تستمر موجات الغناء خلال المرحله
المقبله
عدمه وجود تركيز دائم لافريقيا في مجلس
الامن قد يساخنه التصريح هو لفقي محمد
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي الذي اكد
ايضا انه من غير مقبوله ان يقرر شخص مكان
اخر وان العالم بحاجه لنظام الدولي جديد
امام وزير
الخارجيه الصينيه الجديد والذي لم يعلق
على الطلب الافريقي بل
تعزيز الشركه الصينيه الافريقيه ولا يبدو
الناس الصين حتى شريك اكبر افريقيا جاهزه
لدعم هذا الطلب
صوره اليوم
الجديده ومشكلات كورونا ومتاعب الاقتصاد
لا يهمه
وتتحول الى بهجه عند جميع الاطفال مهما
كان سنهم
وفي فيديو اليوم ما كان ينقص رجال الاطفاء
في خطيف الاوكرانيه هو سقوط صاروخ روسي
على مخزن للالعاب الناريه
لا لا الاطفاء ليله الثلاثاء ليس في
الاستمتاع بهذه الالعاب الناريه وانما في
محاوله للهرب من الاصابه
يبعث البهجه على اهالي خارقين باكثر رعب
في قلوب رجال الاطفاء